this is Steve wontrope with collider and
I am thrilled to be with part of the
cast of The Rings of power I'm not as
excited as Stephen Colbert because he's
on and operating on another level but I
might be just behind him in terms of my
excitement for this series
um and the footage that came out today
is spectacular I'm just curious is that
it was that footage like sometimes
trailers lie a little bit but is this
footage like really representative of
the scale and scope of the series
because it's nuts no it's not because
it's even better yeah
but I feel enough I have I have been
talking about this uh and seen you know
how you see some trailers and and you go
whoa that film looks amazing I want to
go and watch it and then you go watching
the best things in the movie
is the trailer so you might as well just
watch the killer it's not the case with
this I promise you because it does look
like Amazon basically said here's a dump
truck of money go make this series
because I couldn't believe the scale
scope the sets the costumes everything
looked incredible I mean
everybody who is involved in this is at
the top of their game that was so
prominent when we were out there the
sets the costumes the the design the
scripts some of the actors
but wouldn't you agree I would 100 agree
I think you'll see some absolute master
class in in across the industry is going
to be in this show and I think the money
is almost Irrelevant in in comparison to
the actual passion that everybody bought
to this project and that will be so
apparent when we see the show one of the
things so I believe most of you the
people that are the fans of the show
have seen the first three episodes I'm
joking around obviously but you guys
have all seen the first three and the
thing about a show like this is
obviously you're on practical sets but
there's a lot of VFX get added and a lot
of fixes in post-production
um so what was it like watching the
finished versions of these episodes even
though you were in it because it it has
to be so different than what you you
know obviously expected it actually
wasn't too different the the sets that
they actually really built them so if if
we were in a forest they'd build a
forest or we went to a location with the
forest or
um I mean you'll you'll see in in the
trailer that was released today
um that crater scene with all of the
fire they but that was on the Sound
Stage and they built that the fire was
also there there was you know obviously
a couple of the flying the flying bits
obviously weren't there but so majority
of the the whole atmosphere was very
much present when we were filming
um and so what was nice though is that
the VFX just like elevated and you like
broaden it and they really bring what
was already to life even more life
within it yeah true and funny enough the
most the most pretending that we had to
do as actors were with each other in our
case
when what you're talking about scale
work yeah because that was the only
thing that that's not right in front of
you you're not eight feet tall right I'm
taller than yeah but even in that sense
they would try and like you know I'd be
hanging off a really tall ladder you
know and I'd be on my knees yeah you
don't want to be honest I've always
platform of the stool yeah and we'd be
so we could at least look at each other
you know so whenever they whenever the
scale that people were amazing because
whenever they could they would it would
be so easy for for me and I wanted to
work with tennis balls the entire season
you know but whenever they could they
would um we would be looking into each
other's eyes and they would take every
effort to do that they facilitated that
didn't they so big pun come on both of
you
I'll choose you
[Laughter]
know I mean they've built like these
streets I mean it is
it's huge it's vast you know it's
incredible and it's like it's a place
that you look at and you'd go you don't
want to live there you might not be able
to afford the rent
is it's incredible so all these crowd
scenes and everything you know and the
mark get stalls and everything is that's
all real that's all been built all those
people are there and that was magical
just to go through that and it's yeah
yeah it kill it it kills me as a movie
fan and as a TV fan so many of these
incredible sets that get built for
things they just disappear and as a fan
I just want to walk through them and
experience it and um I mean I know
you've been asking you'll probably be
able to do that one day I'm sure well
they did it with hobbiton in terms of
you know that's in New Zealand but um
obviously if you actually could have
like if you you worked on a lot of the
sets you saw a lot of the stuff if you
could actually keep one of those sets in
like the backyard which of the sets that
you worked on that you saw would you
want to keep my workshop without a
doubts
that's good it's a really cool set yeah
yeah because it's it's as we've said
about City you know they built it's it's
totally complete you know you could live
in there quite happily you know there's
steps out of it it's it's it's totally
enclosed there's a reading room there's
there's uh you can sit down you can make
a drink can you wash the dishes there
okay
I wanna support me today that my shirt
is like a dish cloth
and keeps referring to it in failed
terms in a lovely way I love dishcloths
however I'm proud of it and I'm wearing
it yeah this is a question for you guys
um I like learning about like actors on
set and how they work so I'm going to
say which of you can always get it on
the first take and which of you is like
take number four before you really got
it
oh yeah
I'm gonna throw you under the someone's
getting to the bus
depends on the moment that it is also
the day that it is some days you'd
you know you're not awake until like 12
midday you know which happens to me
quite a lot of the time
you know um but um yeah like there was
there was a
yeah
um
there was a lot of you know there was a
lot of like
oh wow
didn't want you to get markella into
trouble
we were given loads of takes that's
that's what was great is that it it felt
in a way like an independent film at
times didn't it that that we we got to
do various versions and kind of go oh
I've got another one in me I've got a
different oh I've just realized
something that we can explore here or a
note would be given so it was like so we
were we were given one thing
we've lost him again he's gone down the
steps again
I just couldn't get something there was
just something that was eluding me and
and I became aware that time was ticking
and you know we had to move on and he
just was like no no we'll keep going
we'll get it we'll get there it's okay
and I felt in such safe hands and I
think that is quite rare on something of
this scale to just go we want to get the
best so if we have to keep going we will
do that until we get it and I think
that's was incredible as an actor it was
a real gift generous really generous
yeah really generous I remember the one
time we were shooting the scene with you
yeah um and uh it was a speech and he
was doing it the you're doing it the
same way slightly different a few times
and then you did that then the last tick
everything was just tend on its head and
yeah you did something completely
different and it was and it's the one
they used and it's because it was
amazing but like but I remember it was
like it was one where you were just like
you were like no no wait wait wait you
know well I brought you back into the
when I when I nearly chucked you out but
then allowed you to come back in
that's no no no no no no no no it's
another one
sorry there's other people listening
so one of the things listen I love the
Lord of the Rings movies but I love the
extended versions more because it
fleshes out more scenes more character
stuff and the reason I'm so excited
about this being a series is that a
series allows like a like a dinner scene
or like things where you can like
actually have conversations that can
take five minutes in a movie you don't
have five minutes to do that it has to
be done in as quick as you can so can
you sort of talk about that aspect of
this being a a TV series can it opens it
up in terms of so much character
development and so many things that
can't be done in a three-hour film I
think it feeds into what we've just said
was the luxury of having the time on set
to to do a few takes and I think that
that that sort of informs the way it's
it's made and you feel you do have that
time and that luxury and uh so and it
was it's a it's a really rare
opportunity to have that to give detail
as well yeah yeah yeah and the show
Runners are such incredible writers and
creators and developers as well that a
lot of the depth of the characters were
already in this grips and in the story
and so while you were collaborating as
an actor you really got to build it from
the ground upwards and there's just so
much detail and so many layers within
each character within each relationship
between each character between each
story in each world and then bringing it
all together and running it all out and
I think it'd be fair to say that every
actor in this show was so passionate
about character development and fleshing
out their characters and they were so
open to that the whole time that was
just a real passion of everybody to make
these characters absolutely
three-dimensional with backstories and
history and wants and desires and
worries and and so yes I totally agree
with you that's the great thing about it
being intelligence and Marco could have
done it in one take
just to get that clear
I like the way you brought it home on
that note I need to wrap with you guys
and I'm just going to say
um sincerely uh congrats on this I know
it's going to be a massive hit and um I
can't wait to talk to you guys with more
specifics once I've seen the show and
I'm just going to say thank you so much
for watching and enjoy Comic-Con thank
you very much